people have always had trouble
pronouncing his name if you don't speak
German it's not at all obvious how
you're supposed to say it a safe bet is
to start with a hard G on ger and end
with a Turk goethe johann wolfgang von
goethe has often been seen as one of
europe's big cultural heroes comparable
to the likes of shakespeare dante and
Homer during his life
Goethe's admirers were impressed by his
literary works but more than any of his
books would impress people at the time
was how he lived his life the kind of
person he was we can pick up some vital
lessons from him gotas first profit job
after law school was as an assistant at
a national tribunal judging cases
between the many minor German states
that at that time made up the Holy Roman
Empire while he was working Goethe fell
in love with a fiancee of one of his
colleagues he then committed a huge
indiscretion and wrote up the love
affair as a novel he called it the
sorrows of young theater the central
character theater is a lightly disguised
self-portrait the book tells the story
of how Verta goethe falls in love with a
young woman charlotte it's a very
detailed description of all the tiny
steps one takes on the road to
infatuation they danced together at one
point their feet accidentally touch unto
the table they smile they write each
other flirtatious little notes it makes
being in love seemed like the most
romantic experience in life better ask
himself what is a life without romantic
love a magic lantern without a lamp this
deeply charming novel was a best-seller
across Europe for the next 25 years
Napoleon boasted he'd read it seven
times the story has a miserable ending
Charlotte doesn't really love theater
and finally rejects him in despair he
kills himself the tragic day numa shows
Goethe beginning to see the limitations
of the romantic view of life romantic
love is deeply attractive but it causes
us immense problems too the core problem
as Goethe came to see it as this
romantic love hopes to freeze a
beautiful moment
it's a summer's evening after dinner
Verta is walking in the woods with his
beloved he wants her to be always like
this so he feels they should get mad
I'd have a house together have children
though in reality marriage will be
nothing at all
like the lovely June night that the
exhaustion bills to pay squabbles in a
sense of confinement by comparison with
the extreme hopes of romanticism real
love as Goethe came to see is always
necessarily a terrible disappointment
that's why Goethe gradually moved away
from romanticism towards an ideology of
love he termed classicism marked by a
degree of pessimism an acceptance of the
troubles that afflict all couples over
time and of the need to abandon some of
the heady hopes of the early days for
the sake of tranquillity in
administrative competence Goethe was a
critic of romantic ideology not because
he was cold-hearted or lacking in
imagination but because he's so deeply
and intimately understood the
attractions of Romanticism and therefore
it's dangerous in April 1775 not long
after his big success with Verta Goethe
got a job as a civil servant Col August
the Duke of vemma appointed him as his
chief adviser and senior administrator
to help run his country Goethe continued
in this employment for most of the rest
of his life his main jobs were his
Minister for Rhodes and as the overseer
of a state-owned silver mining operation
it can sound like a strange move for a
very successful creative figure as if
the winner of the Booker Prize became a
civil servant we just assumed that art
and literature are at odds with an
enthusiasm for government administration
but Goethe didn't see it that way
he felt that understanding
administration would help him put big
ideas into practice later in his life
instead of writing about how good it
would be to have a national theater he
was able to establish one and instead of
just saying that cities should have
green spaces he was able to rev up the
governmental machinery into action and
actually create a model urban park in
September 1786 after ten years in the
vimar civil service when his 40th
birthday was coming into view Goethe got
fed up with Germany the cold the bad
food and this was key for him the lack
of sex so he went a room with a very
classical idea of the
point of travel the outer journey was
intended to support an inner journey
towards maturity he felt that there were
parts of himself that could only be
discovered in Italy but like many
visitors to Rome when he got there he
felt a bit disappointed in the famous
book of poems he later wrote about his
experience the Roman elegies he
describes how the great city seemed to
be filled with lifeless ruins that were
famous but didn't actually mean anything
to him speak to me use stones he pleads
it's a feeling many later visitors have
had Goethe realized that what he needed
was not a more elaborate guidebook but
the right person to have an affair with
someone who would embody the spirit of
the place he was in in his poems he
describes the woman he meets whom he
calls Faust inna
they spend lazy afternoons in bed she's
not a great intellectual but she
breathed the spirit of Rome she tells
him about her life about the buildings
she passes on her way to the market it's
the pantheon a baroque church designed
by Bernini which she hadn't even
realized were famous they were just the
buildings that happen to be around when
she was getting the milk and the
aubergines for Goethe the point of
travel isn't relaxation or just taking a
break from routine he had a bigger goal
in mind the aim of travel is to go to a
place where we can find a missing
ingredient of our own maturity one of
the most striking things about Goethe is
how much he did how broad his horizons
were and how wide his interests came to
be he explored this particularly through
his most famous work Faust Goethe worked
on Faust all his life the earlier
sketches go back to his teens and he
only decided he was done with it when he
was in his early 80s Faust comes in two
parts and together the performance takes
about 13 hours Goethe himself never saw
the whole thing and few people have ever
since Faust is a medieval academic and
scholar he's very learned but he doesn't
do very much he's unfulfilled in love he
hasn't made any money and he has no
power his knowledge is sterile his life
feels pointless and he wishes he could
die but then he is visited by a devil
called mephistopheles who offers him
boundless energy good looks and the
ability to do whatever he wants the
question is what will Faust want to do
the first danger for Faustus to just
stay an academic who resists worldly
impact with the devil's help he could be
the ultimate bookworm he could get his
hands on the oldest rarest manuscripts
but Faust gets weary of words and longs
for action
now the second danger is that he will
use his new powers to gratify every
sensual appetite he might become just a
pure head Ernest Faust goes some way
down this path he goes to a bar and gets
everyone very drunk he goes to a huge
orgy but then he realizes that what he
really seeks is beauty and love and this
leads him on from sex and alcohol the
third danger is that Foust will become a
confident but shallow political leader
but in the second part of the play Faust
pursues a grander purpose eventually he
organizes the development of a new
country somewhat reminiscent of the
Dutch Republic which at that time was
the most enlightened and successful
society in the world Faust is a morality
tale for all of us he shows us both the
pitfalls of life and how we might avoid
them Faust knows a great deal but he
resists being an academic he loves sex
but he doesn't give way to debauchery
he likes power but he doesn't use it for
megalomania he puts it to work in the
service of noble ends Faust career path
is not unlike Goethe's Faust is
essentially tracing for us a theory of
how to live a full life
he's very interested in ideas but not a
scholar he visits Italy but he doesn't
stay there he goes back to work he tries
out administration and learns how to
wield power but once he's mastered this
side of himself he moves on the Faustian
idea is that in order to develop fully
we have to flirt with things that are
quite dangerous but hold on to a sense
of higher purpose Goethe was the last
European to do a certain kind of
remarkable things to write great novels
and plays and also to play a significant
role in science his interests range
through geology meteorology Physiology
and chemistry and his most important
work was in botany in 1790 he produced
this study the metamorphosis of plants
and a book on optics and color called
the theory of colors was published in
1810 thereafter this combination of very
significant work in the arts and in the
sciences disappears from Europe
civilization Goethe gives us some
guidance as to why this has happened
he's a hero for people of a more
literary and artistic sensibility who
are attracted from a distance to the
broad subject matter of science but who
find the details a bit less appealing
Goethe like science that you can do
yourself by looking carefully at the
world around you for example he did a
lot of his research on plants in his own
back garden in vemma he did a lot of his
research on optics with candles and
colored pieces of paper in his study he
liked the training this gave in asking
oneself what do I actually see Goethe
was very interested in a psychological
aspect of our relationship to the sorts
of things that science investigates
plants light stones rather than exclude
the issues of personal meaning Goethe
sees these essential to the proper and
full investigation of nature Goethe was
worried by the direction that science
was taking which he particularly
associated with the work of Isaac Newton
as grotus orhid the academic
professional scientist wasn't interested
in a personal meaning of the things they
were investigating and thereby helped to
kill the subject as he aged Goethe kept
on working and he kept on seeking love
and sex in his 70s he fell in love with
a woman called Ulrika his passion was
unrequited he died at his house in vimar
in 1832 aged 83 we have so much to learn
from him we don't often hear people
declaring a wish to be a little more
like Goethe but if we did the world
would definitely be a more vibrant and
humane place
you